welcome back to cvs saturday morning
this week a teenager made aviation
history by becoming the youngest woman
to fly solo around the world on thursday
zara rutherford completed a five-month
32 thousand mile journey that took her
from europe across north and south
america along the pacific rim and over
the middle east and africa to return
home again in record time
not many 19 year olds can say they've
circled the globe and only one can say
she's flown herself zara rutherford came
full circle this week when she landed
her ultra light aircraft at the same
belgian airport where her voyage began
back in august it's just really crazy i
haven't quite processed it i think i
mean coming here i was basically into
just trying to imagine what it'd be like
to finally be home after five months
along the way rutherford traversed 41
countries on five different continents
flying over natural wonders and man-made
marvels the trip was bumpy at times a
russian visa issue kept her grounded in
alaska for days along the way she dodged
thunderstorms fought the fog and even
flew through california's wildfire smoke
when cloudy conditions caused her to
lose radio contact on her approach to
greenland rutherford texted her parents
i'm alive when she finally landed safely
both pilots themselves rutherford's
parents knew what was in store when she
left on her journey very aware of the
risks but i think she
needs to fly away it's it's her dream
and she needs to live it now back at
home and in the record books rutherford
is focused on her next challenge
studying computer science in college and
one day becoming an astronaut all while
inspiring girls and young women to
pursue educations in stem related fields
but she had one thing to do for herself
just after landing well so i've been
waiting for the sandwich that's like
from a sandwich shop that's like really
nearby and i've been waiting five months
to get it so i'm really looking forward
to getting it
soon
and one thing that stood out she said
the kindness of strangers along the way
is she got waylaid in different places
like alaska they hosted her a family
even though they had a newborn when she
left that newborn was five weeks old so
she'd been there for over half of this
little baby's life amazing wow
love the story